so the reason I'm saying all this about
the costs and time spent
is for anybody who thinks that it's done
to make money
it's far from that
of course everybody needs
to be paid or what you know it's nice to
give give but uh
I'm spending time money electricity and
everything else doing it
so anyhow as long as I've covered my
costs
then I'm happy the first person to get
the certificate is um
Scott Worthy
so he's the first person this is the
first certificate and there's seven now
that I'm going to be awarding
this certificate is
the finished article is exactly in every
details as far as I'm concerned the same
as what cytosense he presented
he also presented Scrolls and he used to
say
that he would spend all night
um writing up the scroll was saying
the exact points so most people who
received the Scrolls around the world
would have had different things put on
them depending on what you thought about
the student and what they should do at
the time
he was he was giving us instructions on
what he he saw us do
so the scroll is a very personal thing
they're not just the same for everybody
I'm I cannot do that and I wouldn't even
attempt to try but doing the Scrolls the
certification will be something I hope
you're proud of and you'll be able to
know that you've been awarded it
I'd like to go back to
obtaining them if you pass all three
sorry all four
uh levels
but you've got a list of points that you
need to look at on each one
then
before you get the fifth level you have
to either buy film or in front of me
show there's going to be obviously
broken down over a day
you're going to have to show me
all four levels in one one-off go
so let's just supposing that in three
four years time
somebody's got to all four levels
they've been working on the the points
that I've
given them with another certificate
to say that I'm I'm happy with what
they're doing but if they want to work
on their own
weaknesses like the thing on the end of
the Joe or the finger sticking out on
the can or holding the Joe with a loose
hand
when they're holding the Joe
then
before they get the fifth certificate
they show me all four in one go
I've got the forms that I've written to
each person
I'm thinking it might sound like an
impossible task and I'm not going to be
expecting
100 Perfection but I am going to expect
them to correct the weaknesses as they
go
what is the point in giving somebody the
fifth level if they haven't worked on
the weakness points I've got my
certificate I can now get on to the next
one that's not how it's going to work
it's going to work that you work hard
between each level
and you try to correct each weakness
I've got a couple in Europe at the
moment who are working on
I couldn't pass them because there was
too many important points
now they're important to me because I
followed cyber CNC for 27 years
and over those years I went from a very
Dynamic Master to one who wanted
Perfection and correction
he saw the world had taken his films and
his books but hadn't ever been trained
by him
and he's he was really annoyed that they
they um they destroyed in his words
his uh
31 Kimmy Joe
um you know they were getting so many
pieces wrong in all the weapon systems
that he was annoyed
therefore this is what my job is is to
try to polish and improve on those
weaknesses
so those that do hold the certificates
have a really good attitude and a good
ability to show high quality weapons of
the awama system
so
because I'm getting older and have body
problems and knees and
spinal problems and things
I will at times get other people to show
the same site of sense he did he got his
son
um to sometimes show for his books and
and we we have to allow you
to see the best we can so if I feel like
I can't show something adequately then I
will ask
uh the students have passed the
certificates to demonstrate
I will not show them if they haven't
passed the level
going back to
some of my students have passed and I've
said that they've got faults have sent
me six and seventh down iwama teachers
around the world of them having the same
faults that have shown me snapshots
screenshots
I said well this person's doing this
but what you have to realize is I'm not
interested
in what another person's doing I'm
giving you what I was taught
us NC often said do this but he didn't
do it himself he was obviously trying at
the end of his life to get us as perfect
as possible that's why he slowed the
system up that's why he wanted two
seconds between each movement
it was very boring it was horrible to do
but I'm now completely understand why he
done it
because I'm going the same way because
the first
um ones I looked at for the first level
even though they were teachers first
second third all the way up to fifth
then
they were demonstrating they weren't
doing a teacher's pace
to be a teacher you have to go slowly
you have to go methodically each piece
must be clear
that's what these bookie was the
certificates are all about I'm not
interested on your demonstration I'm
interested on are you teaching from
beginner upwards clearly precisely at a
pace that anybody can follow
so there'll be a series of films thank
you for listening I hope we can
make the world better
quality in irama weapons this is my aim
this is my goal thank you for your time